los efectos de la guerra se hacen notar
esto es nacido en irak
los ciudadanos iraquíes deben recibir
una parte del petróleo lo exigimos desde
ahora y hasta que se cumplan nuestras
demandas el alza en los precios de los
combustibles preocupa en todo el mundo y
en bagdad la capital iraquí también el
aumento de los precios de los alimentos
donde el costo del aceite casi se
cuatriplicó
pueden creer que tengo que pagar 15
dólares por una lata de aceite como lo
voy a hacer también hay gastos en la
casa en la escuela cómo vamos a vivir
ucrania prohibió la exportación de trigo
avena y otros alimentos básicos y a 2400
kilómetros está teniendo impacto en el
mayor importador de trigo del mundo
egipto depende del gran ucraniano aunque
el gobierno asegura tener reservas para
todo 2022 al otro lado del mediterráneo
en túnez la preocupación es mayor y
caixa jet presidente tunecino mandó una
advertencia en plena escasez
quiero que sea una guerra implacable
contra los especuladores criminales pero
la crisis también llega hasta los países
occidentales en alemania los precios del
diésel están en niveles récord mientras
hay una escasez de entre 60 y 80 mil
conductores
la guerra de ucrania ha provocado que
los precios del diésel se disparen de
manera exorbitante actualmente tenemos
entre 50 y 60 centavos por litro de
costos adicionales en este segmento
lamentablemente tenemos que trasladar
este aumento de costos a nuestros
clientes
los impactos en las exportaciones clave
desde ucrania y rusia también afectan al
transporte en un aumento del precio que
acabará afectando a todos los productos
transportados